all right tanya
tanya uh where'd you grow up where are
you from florida originally uh
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents i have both my parents
uh seven boys and me my mom didn't have
any more kids so i was 15 which was
girls
uh how would you describe your childhood
well
it was a good job my mom sent me the
best schools i went to what we call
uh over the bridge which means i went to
a white all white school
uh higher education
i pretty much had a child i had a little
my solicitation for my uncles
so when did that happen yeah when i was
like uh
11 to 12
i let my finally let my mom know what
was going on
she stand did you do something about it
yeah in a sort of kind of way she
believed i was mine at first
but then she just believed me because
someone else came forward and spoke on
it
i was raised with my birth mom and my
uh which i call mom which is mom to me
my birth mom was addicted to crack so
it's
a like uh i could stay went on into the
family
so i used to do stuff to get back at her
me and her couldn't stand each other so
other than that i had a
perfectly good shot you have to left
turn on what age
17 seventeen where'd you go at seventeen
uh new york
uh state money went to new york came
back
then it came here to california i never
just never went back
and today you're living on skid row yes
where are you staying in the tent or
in attendance how long have you been
living on the streets
um all my life really no
but uh for last um
two months which is crazy because i have
a home to go to
you do yes but
you prefer to stay out here yes in my
addiction because the drugs are
readily available yes and i don't get
high or
anything at home i never gotten high at
home i tried that once and that didn't
go so well
uh the feeling was it was kind of [ __ ]
up
america's sure it's kind of [ __ ] up
and then i was thinking what if my kids
came home and or
came home and caught me high i've never
tried tried never to let them see me
high
the whole time i was pregnant i have
twin girls the whole time i was pregnant
i've never got high with them the day i
found out i was high
i mean my friend i was high found out i
was pregnant uh i stopped i went to a
program
stopped using drugs so i was clean 20
years before i started back
using and i've been using maybe the last
year
year and a half and all these years on
the streets
how have you supported yourself uh
i actually worked for the last 20 years
last 20 years i had a
regular job i was the production
supervisor of the company
so i actually worked
i caught cancer so that and a lot of
other
relationship problems and finances all
of that just started
bubbling bubbling bubbling and
i guess i just went to what i knew that
would take a
pain away thought away all that away
addiction back to my addiction
so i started back even and how are you
supporting yourself
today well what i used to do
prostitution
at times but not all the time i
clean i uh because i usually go
other section i have another spot i
usually go to i clean houses
i've come i've done wholing
uh i don't just let it be prostitution
no
funnier you have cancer must be
stressful and that probably
makes you want to smoke yeah and it
takes pain
the other nights i can go to sleep i go
to sleep shaking crying
and in pain so sometimes to me it's
you know all of that at once is very
so-so
you still have contact with your family
at all yes
yes this last uh
month yeah
this last month i had me want to talk to
my daughters
because uh
because that means mother's day
i've never missed a birthday nothing
but at that time i got onto
something that made a lot of money and
i didn't want to let that go
so i didn't get to go home mother's day
and that really [ __ ] my head so i
haven't called
which i know she's worried about me
but
how'd you first get introduced to crack
my mother
[Music]
watching her yeah uh like a savage with
two mothers
well i didn't consider my birth mother
my mother i thought she was my sister
until i was older or
someone in the family uh
watching her get high and watching her
be so evil towards me when she saw used
to see me
or is cutting my hair my hair used to be
way down my back
she's cut it one weekend she said oh you
got split ends i'm gonna press your hair
and next thing you know i'm just seeing
all my hair fall on the ground
she just cut my hair off
uh come to find out she was
jealous of the way my mom was treating
me
uh this life i was given um
that she felt she wasn't because she
also raised her it was just her mother's
her birth mother's sister so
she's just she never really harbored on
why she
hated me so much i felt she hated me
she never really told me that but before
she died
she made amends with me of how she
treated me how she
did with me and that was one of the
reason i went back to florida
and you know to have you know to
have closure with all that feelings i
have for her
but it wasn't until i was an adult that
we
could talk like i would call her i
called her her name
until later on down the line i started
calling her mom
but that wasn't until my [ __ ] other
mom was passed away
but yeah watching her taking her drugs
hiding them from her
flushing them down the toilet i've
actually one time wanted to die so i
took her drugs picking they repealed or
something that could kill me fast
and because i didn't want to because my
birth my other mom made me stay with her
for a summer
and that was like the worst to me she
lived in the projects the ghetto
and i never lived in together
that was just like me coming from a
white home coming stay and skip bro
i'm like what the [ __ ] you know
now i love being at places like this
because
i don't know this it's crazy because i
have a three bedroom
three bedroom condo in lakewood
and i don't have to be outside but i
prefer to be honest
what is it about skid row that makes it
so attractive it's not only just girl
it's anywhere
i used to be in south central because i
used to be in south central or
somewhere other it's just
i don't know it's like somebody needs me
that's the best way i can describe
because every day i meet somebody that
need that
that uh by me helping them helps me
that's the best way i can describe it
because i've already signed up to a
program i'm just waiting on a bed
uh i try to go to church when i can
it's not it's people
it's like i have a purpose i don't know
what the purpose is but i'm searching
for that purpose
i know it's to get out of drugs i don't
know that much because some days i don't
even get high
that's how i know it's not really the
drugs i don't get hot some days i don't
get high
just eat sleep read whatever
is this your lowest point right now no
this is happening my lois my lowest
point was
being filthy being just like some of the
people i see out here
filthy dirty just didn't know what to do
just gave up
just went into psychosis and going to
this
place that i knew i went to in long
beach and they took me in
yeah and brought me back from that yes
because i have i'm bipolar
with uh schizophrenic genesis so
what kind of emotions do you go through
all kinds of emotions
someday i could be happy something sad
some days if i'm and i have nerve damage
so
if i'm not on my gaba opinion or you
know medication for a long time at the
times and uh
the drugs the [ __ ] the headaches
all that stuff start combining and
building up building up building up and
then
my ultra personality takes over and
she's not nice she's she's not nice at
all
she doesn't take any [ __ ] from the
guys guys
like i will cuss the guy at frasier and
i cuss to grow up
i just have that go-to attitude
and she pushes it forward
when she comes forward
just she surprised me that things come
up my mouth
and so i was i said i said that to you
and like yeah i said but was it true
and they were like yeah but she said i'm
very
and without the personalities i'm very
blunt some people take that harsh
but hey we live in a hardships world you
don't be blunt until the reality of
what's going on with you
you're still gonna be in that delusion
do you feel like maybe you're walking in
your mom's footsteps in some way
no sometimes
yeah it's interesting that you're not
you don't feel like you're
you don't need to use every day no i
don't
so you think maybe you're just addicted
to this this lifestyle down here
i don't know could be because
i have money i go sleeping money i go to
sleep with drugs
so it's not like i have got to have it i
got no it doesn't get me like that
but i think that's more or less well my
counselor says that
he said i've had a couple of counselors
and i want to be in their counselor
now i'm not delighted i'm telling you
each program i've been to three programs
and each time i left there they wanted
me to work there
but like i say some that's why i say
sometimes when i'm out here
it's like i have a purpose i come across
people
every day and
like i can say like it's south central
if you walk with me every walk with me
more than an hour you're like you can't
know all these people
and i'm like believe it or not i do know
all these people that's waving at me or
that's hollering at me or
all the way down to the postman because
that's just the type of person i am
you know and somebody we all go do the
same thing
the same same same [ __ ] just different
days
different ways we handle it different
things we do you know i see stuff
i don't just see stuff in black and
white see stuff with color
you gotta see stuff too like some of the
people are walking around talking to
this old
that's not them that's the illusion or
this thing that's holding them gripped
in their side their own mind they're
trapped in their own minds
you know they're not just crazy people
hey if that's the case i'm crazy
i i go check myself in the exit as every
other sometimes when i'm feeling
really all out there i'll go check
myself in there tell them i'm having a
manic attack
they hurry up and open the doors
do you think you'd be down here the rest
of your life i don't know you're gonna
know how i answered it no
you're you're close to getting out it
seems yeah it's to me it's like a face
i think when you said is this the lowest
i think this is as low as my faces man
i've been to her i just come there all
the time but i never stayed more than a
day or two
this is as long as i've ever stayed down
so what would you say like i'm
practicing myself and not punishing
myself oh
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
how old are you i'll be six this year
november
you're you're 59 yeah hard to believe um
don't give up hope addiction stays with
you the rest all your life
you could stop i was coming 20 years
and drop them down you could be back
using it again
there's no there's no excuse and there's
an excuse
but just don't give a hope we all got a
purpose and
sometimes it's time to find our purpose
of what our purpose in life is
we all got different paths we all may
walk the same path look like we walk in
the same path or we're not
everybody's different guys has a
different purpose for all of us
all right tanya well thank you so much
for talking with me and i wish you the
best of luck
now you make me cry early in the morning
okay you said i do them let's
read my bible